PAUL KINLAN: Hi, I'm
Paul Kinlan,
developer advocate to Google.
And today we're going to look at
the Sketchbot experiment in
the Web Lab project.
And with [? Roger ?] and
[? Mattias ?] from B-Reel, do
you guys want to give yourselves
a little bit of an
introduction?
ROGER: I'm [? Roger, ?]
I'm a creative technologist
[INAUDIBLE], and I've been the
technical leader
of the project.
MATTIAS: And I'm
[? Mattias, ?]
also a creative technologist
at B-Reel and been working
with several of the projects.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So welcome to our little studio
and humble campus,
Google campus in London.
So we're going to talk about
the Web Lab project and the
Sketchbot experiment today.
For those who haven't seen Web
Lab, chromeweblab.com I
believe is the correct URL.
MATTIAS: That's right.
PAUL KINLAN: Whoo.
It's a series of five real world
Chrome experiments that
also have a browser-based
interface as well.
And the really cool thing about
Chrome Web Lab is that
the way that you experience
the experiment inside the
museum is the exact same way
that you experience it inside
the browser anywhere
in the world.
I'm really proud of it,
I think it's awesome.
I think it's a very nice thing
inside the museum.
Check our previous Hangout where
we actually went into a
little bit more depth about
Chrome Web Lab.
It's cool, check it out.
Today we're going to talk about
Sketchbots which is one
of the five experiments.
Do you want to give a
brief introduction?
MATTIAS: Yeah, it is basically
eight robots in the museum
drawing your face in sand to
represent how the computers
are seeing you.
PAUL KINLAN: Right, so it
basically takes your photo
inside the museum or online and
then draws it in the sand?
I mean, that sounds
a bit weird.
So we can draw a photo from
here, in the sand and then see
what it looks like later on?
MATTIAS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool, man.
I sound like a real
[INAUDIBLE].
I know what it's like.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: It is pretty
cool, this one.
So as we can see on the screen,
this is the main menu
interface at the moment with
Sketchbots and we can see a
couple of the actual machines
inside the museum.
Let's launch the experiment.
That's pretty cool.
I can say this, every single
time we do a Hangout, I love
the loading screens,
they're very nice.
So who did the loading
screens?
Was it any of you?
MATTIAS: Yeah, it was us and
also our art director who did
the small animations in Flash
and exported them with
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL KINLAN: Really?
MATTIAS: So it made [INAUDIBLE]
animations in the
start in the logo, in
the corner as well.
PAUL KINLAN: So how
come you use--
I didn't know this.
How come you used
Flash off with?
Is it to the timeline, the way
that you can do timelines and
everything, makes it easier?
ROGER: Yeah, we couldn't find
any HTML5 that was right for
taking this animation.
MATTIAS: Because it's a lot of
gradients and when two shapes
cross each other they should
have a separate color
in just that area.
So it made it much simpler to
work with animations in Flash.
PAUL KINLAN: So that's
pretty interesting,
that's pretty cool.
OK, so let's look at this now.
So this is the Sketchbot
experiments.
I do Spoonerisms quite a lot.
I end up saying the wrong
words completely.
But this is a live stream on the
right hand side from the
actual museum.
ROGER: From the museum.
Yes, so it is what's happening
at the moment in the museum.
So
PAUL KINLAN: I think obviously
the museum is probably
closed right now.
It's probably about sevenish.
ROGER: But the robots are--
PAUL KINLAN: --but
the robots work.
You said there was four.
Is it split for four people
at the museum
and four people online?
When the museum is closed,
does it go to all eight?
MATTIAS: Yeah, all eight
for online users.
PAUL KINLAN: So let's have a
quick jump in because I want
to ask you some stuff about
[INAUDIBLE] and all that type
of stuff as well.
I'm going to take my photo.
And let's just briefly talk
about this page, right?
It doesn't look like there's
lots going on.
But I want to talk about
one over here.
So at the top of the screen--
whoops, sorry.
At the top of the screen here,
we've got chromeweblab.com
wants to use your camera.
Now what API is this that's
producing this alert?
MATTIAS: This is Get User Media
that allows you to get
the camera straight in the
browser instead of going
through a plug-in.
PAUL KINLAN: And this was only
a relatively recent edition
for you all?
ROGER: When we started the
project this wasn't existent.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I remember
was-- did I say this in this
one or the one prior to this?
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: I can't actually
remember whether when we
launched this, when we started
this we kept saying that Get
User Media was like two
or three months off.
And we kept going like two
And then I think is was the
week that you launched or
opened the museum and it finally
landed in stable
Chrome and you guys linked
that across.
So what were you using prior
to this to actually get the
webcam data?
MATTIAS: Flash.
PAUL KINLAN: Just
a simple Flash.
So how would you this time--
I'm always interested about this
because I never got on to
the Flash bandwagon when
I was developing.
My prior life was asp.net.
That's interesting.
You would take something
from the Flash object.
How would you get it
into the page?
Would you--
MATTIAS: --so it's a bridge
between Flash and JavaScript.
We send the raw data of
the image and draw it
with that data URL.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh wow, OK.
So you used the data URL?
MATTIAS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So that makes
this-- well there is lot of
overhead generally so you
wouldn't need to do animations
for this but--
MATTIAS: We started off trying
to do that and got quite good
results in just sending
the data through.
But we decided to use one
image in the end.
PAUL KINLAN: So let's talk about
an image, let's allow
the camera.
Hey.
I'm not sure how well this is
going to work with the lights
and everything.
There we are.
ROGER: So this is quite
interesting because we wanted
not to have this position
yourself in the frame.
We wanted to have something
more seamless.
So this is using face detection
to detect your face.
PAUL KINLAN: How did you
do the face detection?
MATTIAS: So it's that a program
called Pittsburgh
Pattern Recognition running
on the server.
So we send off your image for
analyzing and it gets back
where your eyes and
mouth and--
PAUL KINLAN: --so all that
[INAUDIBLE] on the server.
You send it to the server and
then bring it back in.
Is that because there was
no JavaScript library?
MATTIAS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So let's
submit this photo.
I'm really happy
with the photo.
Although there is someone photo
bombing on the side.
I was in Liverpool the other
week and I was walking through
with my son and there was a
model photo shoot going on and
my son was standing there photo
bombing everything and
the photographer was getting
really annoyed.
So sorry.
Anyway, what happened there?
ROGER: Here we will take
the face first and
then we align it.
With [INAUDIBLE].
And here we can turn it into a
binary image, just black and
white which is quite interesting
because we're
using elective press
[? hold. ?]
After that we do the
etch detection.
And finally, we draw the vector
lines with the curves.
PAUL KINLAN: So we need to do
these lines because they want
to translate it to the robots,
the instructions
that draw the commands?
ROGER: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So you mentioned
before that you basically send
the stuff to the server, the
image to the server and did
the process.
But in the user interface we
saw quite a lot of user
interactivity in the sense that
it showed you a line in
the image to verticalize it.
I mean, each of those steps,
was that done by the server
itself and then you--
MATTIAS: No.
Those are done with
web workers.
So it's workers in the
background processing all your
data to make it a smooth
animation.
PAUL KINLAN: So is the first
step to basically detect where
the face is?
ROGER: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And then all the
rest of it is [INAUDIBLE]
inside the browser?
ROGER: Yeah.
It plays inside.
It is done with animation.
MATTIAS: And we do it on the
server side as well when you
submit your photos to your
robots to make sure that no
one injects dirty pictures.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
I can imagine.
So that is pretty cool.
So the point of--
how to say this right.
So you went through a couple of
steps where you desaturated
it and then you turned it into
a binary image and then you
did the outline with
the bezier curves?
I mean, is that a standard
process?
I'm interested in this from how
you actually worked out
the steps that you should take
to make the commands.
ROGER: It is quite standard.
I mean would you want one of
the [INAUDIBLE] to get from
your normal picture to a binary
image where you can do
etch detection and then create
the vector lines.
What we found out is that this
process from creating when you
have a desaturated image like
a black and white image and
you want to create a binary
image, they are just black and
white pixels.
If you are using an [INAUDIBLE]
to do that.
If the user had some kind of
shadow in the face for
example, this was spoiling
everything because it got all
that-- so the vector line would
do something like this
so it would be only
half a face.
So what we ended up using
was one thing
called adaptive threshold.
That what it does instead of
having one threshold and if
the pixels are darker than this,
they are black and if
they are lighter,
they are white.
What we do is each of the
specific pixels has its own
threshold that depends
on the neighbors.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh yeah, OK.
ROGER: Even though you have a
very dark area, you still can
difference in the outlines
of the mouth and the
eyes and the ears.
PAUL KINLAN: That's nice.
So you are using the average
of all of the nine pixels
around it essentially.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah I see that in PhotoShop.
People can write their own, I
don't remember those types of
thing, I'm absolutely
terrible about that.
It is pretty cool.
So at this point we've made the
series of bezier curves
and everything.
Now I actually want to ask this
as a general question
because the reason why I want
to ask this question is
because I have a presentation
to do.
And I want to take a picture
of me, but I want to do a
rough outline of me as,
basically as a bezier curve
because WebKit Mask and WebKit
Clip Regions and everything
take basically what is known
as a SPG path essentially.
Is that something
you did here?
How did you work out the best
bezier curve to go?
How did you work out-- if this
one really interests-- you got
my two eyes there and you know
they are in completely
enclosed paths.
How did you do that?
MATTIAS: It's following
the edge and
trying to connect them.
So you're following the
edge between the
black and the white.
And if they aren't connected,
then we close the path when it
gets all the way around.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, and
it's that simple?
MATTIAS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: I was hoping
my question
would go on a lot longer.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: So do you know much
about the process between
then sending this to the
actual bots themselves?
I mean because they are two
normally quite physically
disconnected machines.
It is not as if the web server
runs on these bots, right?
So we'll send this to AppEngine
I presume, something
similar to that.
And then how does that data then
get to the bot itself?
MATTIAS: So this is done by
our partner, Tellart, who
built all the robots.
And basically we submit
it to a big queue.
And then the bots itself, I
think they actually have a
small computer running,
or it could be a
virtual instance of it.
But they say I'm ready to do
something new and they get the
next one in the queue in a
central distribution of them.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
I heard some rumors, I don't
know whether they are true.
So the Sketchbots themselves
which I hope show the video of
my face at least
getting drawn.
I didn't save it, oh no.
OK yes, you can have contact.
That's my email address
for everyone.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: It's fine,
I'm public anyway.
OK, cool.
So this is where we know
they are busy, right?
But what we can do at least
anyways is we can show what
the actual sketch looked
like as well.
And that's because we record
the actual arm and
everything, don't we?
MATTIAS: Yeah, uh huh.
So now we have yours saved
in the curves.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, wow.
Yes.
I'm your plus-one there.
I'll tweak it like that.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
So what happens here now is that
it'll go off, it's still
in the queue, it hasn't been
processed yet but this is my
client-side representation of
what's just been drawn.
And at some point in the future
it will, well I don't
know how long it will take, but
it'll then go off and draw
it on the machine.
I heard a rumor that there was
like, do you know about this
rumor where they tried
57 different
types of sand or something?
MATTIAS: Haven't heard that.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: I heard this rumor
that basically what
happened in the project was that
they needed to make sure
that the consistency, basically
what is drawn out in
the commands.
And if we look at the right
hand side, you can see it
working here now with
the arm moving,
drawing someone's face.
MATTIAS: Your face.
PAUL KINLAN: I hope
it is my face.
It is a rather beautiful
face, isn't it?
You didn't say yes.
You were supposed to say yes.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: But basically
it is going to draw.
It draws something three
or four faces at times.
It looks really cool with the
shadow casting across.
But then the face comes round,
not the face but the sand pit
moves around, wipes out
one of the faces and
then draws the next.
And the rumor that I heard was
to get the consistency so that
the face was already wiped out
from the arm that flattens
everything.
But then the arm that actually
does the drawing itself, if it
was too thick it didn't draw
right or something, and if it
was too thin it didn't
draw right as well.
[INAUDIBLE] if they can just
find the right sand.
I don't know, that's
an urban legend.
But you heard it first here.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: It is either true
or it's completely false.
That's pretty cool.
The one thing I'd like to talk
about as well is that we do
have a little How
It Works button.
So if you like this and you
want to learn a little bit
more about the browser
technology behind it, we do
have some more information
about the Web Workers.
And I don't know that many
people who use Web Workers, so
you guys using that
is pretty cool.
So actually to jump on the
point of the Web Workers.
I know I'm going all
over the place now.
And this is what proper
planning is meant for.
You're use of the Web Workers,
was that for everything to do
with image?
MATTIAS: Yeah so all the image
processing is done in--
PAUL KINLAN: --so how did it
work right because there was
multiple steps.
You desaturated, then black
and white thinged.
Thinged?
And then you went around
with the bezier curve.
Did you orchestrate?
Was that one big process
in the Web Worker?
MATTIAS: No, it was calling
different, especially when it
comes to the de-saturation and
the adaptive threshold.
It's a lot of the same just with
different values to get
it into the animation to--
PAUL KINLAN: OK, so you
basically get the Web Worker
to do a small piece of work
and then it'll deliver the
result and then you'll
orchestrate that with the
animation and then--
MATTIAS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Nice, OK.
So the actual Web Worker itself,
how did you get the
data to [? run ?]
[? out ?] because Post Messages
normally takes strings.
And in a lot of cases then you
can do JavaScript objects and
transferables as well to try
and deliver the data
efficiently.
How did you get the
data between?
Was it one basic [INAUDIBLE]
decoded image?
ROGER: Yeah, I believe it was
sending in an image and
sending it back.
MATTIAS: I think so, yeah.
I can't remember
now with the--
ROGER: We'll find out.
PAUL KINLAN: That's interesting
because I know a
lot of people who
have [INAUDIBLE]
to do stuff with Web Workers
but can't send
in that much data.
It's like they don't know
whether it's worth the benefit
of actually using the Web
Worker instead of
processing it in.
I'm presuming it was very
worth it in this project
because actually de-saturating
an image of a multiple steps
and animating it at
the time is pretty
processor intensive, right?
ROGER: Yeah.
Otherwise everything freezed and
then you couldn't see any
of the animation.
MATTIAS: You don't want to lock
the user interface while
doing some image processing.
PAUL KINLAN: I think that has
been key with a lot of this
project is that we've tried
to have this seamless user
experience flow throughout
the whole thing.
There should be no jank.
Yank or jank.
I never know which way they say
it in America, but I think
it is jank.
There are stops are in between
animations and even a 20
millisecond delay, you can
notice it when scrolling and
all that type of stuff.
So I think it is pretty
interesting how you use Web
Workers in this project.
MATTIAS: And I think it changed
also during the
process of this project where it
was copying all the data in
the beginning and now
it transfers the
data so it gets unusable.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, so this uses
the transferable objects?
MATTIAS: Yeah, we had
that switch and
while we were working.
We couldn't understand why it
was where we couldn't use the
data anymore.
PAUL KINLAN: That's pretty
interesting because as a bit
of background for this.
So Web Workers, you can deliver
data in two ways.
You can post-- one way,
post message.
That means you have to send
message from one process into
another process.
And it's actually relatively
heavyweight to be able to do
that because you have to
serialize, say it was a two
megabyte string, like a base-64
encoded string or something.
You have to take that string,
serialize it, pass it across
the IPC like jump essentially.
De-serialize it, it do
the work on it and
then send it back.
Do the same thing as well.
So you end up with four or five
copies of the same piece
of data, or manipulated
data at least.
And to some extent, what
happened probably about eight
months ago I think it was,
WebKit introduced post message
with transferables.
And the idea behind
transferables is that it is
zero memory copy.
So the idea, and I keep
saying the idea is.
The theory this time.
The reason why we want to do
this is we want to make sure
that you have data in one
application, you deliver it
another application of the
webpage, nearly instantly by
saying we're going to copy
the memory across.
You don't do a copy of memory,
you pass it from one
application to another.
It's pretty quick.
We've got some stats on
html5rocks.com which actually
tell you some of the benefits
of using it.
The problem is it introduces a
bit of a different programming
model where if you have some
data in the ray, for instance
on the client, you lose control
of it when you send it
to a remote application.
But it's a lot faster.
So check it out.
I think that's it for
this experiment.
MATTIAS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, so join us
next time for our next
Hangout, where we're going to
talk about one of our other
most awesome experiments.